Warner Brothers presents half of one
movie in 2d which I'm not gonna lie
that's cool
[Music]
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 so this movie marks the beginning
of the end for the Harry Potter movies
and fans everywhere just feeling the
tears and these are dark times for Harry
Potter and his friends ever since the
incident with Dumbledore dawn is the
school aspect that made the movies kind
of family is this is full-fledged war
persecution prejudice death you know not
the funnest of times God willing he
lives through this whole ordeal Harry
Potter will look back on these times
like Tom Arnold looks back on Roseanne
Wow that sucked and I will remember it
forever what I do it again hell no even
if it was the thing that made me really
famous now I personally love the Harry
Potter books I hate reading and I love
those books they're actually quite good
and what irritates me about most of the
Harry Potter movies is they seem to
change things or alter things or leave
things out just for the sake of doing it
it seems like that anyway but hey they
split the last book into two movies so
there is no more of that right now
they'll always do that there were
moments in this movie that were changed
or altered from the book that I think
could have remained the same as the book
it's just all a matter of like one line
of dialogue or a 30-second clip that
would have made just all the difference
I mean since this movie's half the story
doesn't have a lot of the action that
the next one's gonna have play up the
emotions for instance don't leave out a
surprisingly touching moment between
Harry and Dudley that was in the book
that was not in this movie yeah safe to
say splitting the book into two movies
does not rid you of alterations if
you've never read the books I think if
you watch the movie you'll be
obliviously content it's like if you
just eat Twizzlers and you never touch
red vines you don't know what you're
missing so you think Twizzlers are just
fine they're great they're good once you
eat red vines though you'll know what
you're missing I thought they nailed the
vibe of the book really well in this
movie I mean the hopelessness of their
whole mission the odds of success being
grossly astronomically low no good stuff
like that but you know when you were
reading the book and you were like dude
they're still camping and then you're
like dude they're still camping that's
pretty much most of the movie that's
what I'm saying it's like a horrible
part of the book or the movie I'm just
saying of the whole thing it's the
slowest part when I heard there was
putting the movie into two parts I was
like so weak that'll give enough time to
tell the whole story I mean that's
really cool that's awesome oh wait that
means it'll cut off before the hits
the fan and and it does this one movie
split into two halves so there's no real
climax in the movie things sequentially
happened there's a bit
tension in a few scenes one of those
scenes being one of the altered scenes
which 30 seconds longer would have made
it just as intense as it was in the book
and then credits like in the trailer you
see scenes that are in the next movie
they're not in this one
tricky Warner Brothers this movie is the
build-up to the climax of the whole
story that'll be in the next movie that
will be a mix of just Green bolts red
bolts and badassery I'm sure when the
next movie comes out combined it'll be
this five-hour epoch they'll just be
awesome and tell them though dude they
are still camping if you're a Harry
Potter fan or even a fan of the Harry
Potter movies only you'll like this
movie if not you will not so I would say
watch this movie so you know what's
going on when Armageddon happens in the
next movie which you're definitely going
to watch also it's the last Harry Potter
don't kid yourself it is good and it's
well done knowing that there's another
one on the way
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more about academic I
was going to take Russia Oh
[Music]